hello everyone and welcome back to round
10 of the magnets Invitational we are
continuing with the match Fabiana Corwin
over see Cara Nakamura we've already
checked out two games so one game was
won by father one game by Nakamura and
two of the games were drawn so here we
are in Game five d Armageddon D
Armageddon round and as I heard and who
won the coin toss and he chose the black
pieces so it's Fabi who gets five
minutes against Nakamura's four and Fabi
needs to win the game to win the match
Nakamura is satisfied with a draw to win
the match so without further ado let's
check it out Fabiano again with d4 we
have Knight to f6 by Nakamura c4 e6 and
again we go into the Queens gambit
declined knight of three b5 Knight to c3
and again he car with his Bishop to e7
we have Bishop to f4 and now Hikaru
castles and III now we have Knight B to
d7 so this is all very standard we have
a trade in the center C captures Knight
captures Knight captures he captures and
now Bishop to d3 so trading something
but again keeping the position alive as
Fabiano really needs to win this game to
win the match and c5 by Hikaru the most
often played move here as it is the
strongest we have castles by a if a B
and C for now challenging this Bishop
Bishop the c2 ending out b5 so this has
all been played before and Fabi just
challenges this structure with b3
attacking c4 and there are a couple of
moves that were played in this position
and Knight of 6 is a normal move g6 is a
known move but the move nakamura played
is a new move in the position which is a
5 so as of move 12 we have a completely
new game we have a trade on c4 5e
captures be captures B captures and now
rook the b1 grabbing the B file for his
rook and now Bishop to b4 not allowing
this rook in any route lifts in the
future but also preventing a rook to e1
so it is a useful square for the bishop
we have h3 by Fabi and now rook to a6 a
nice rock lift by by Nakamura but for
the moment it's
very hard to shift it over to the king
site to help out with the attack due to
Fabrice bishop repair we have Queen d2
developing the Queen connecting rooks
and now Knight to f6 and as if F square
is no longer covered by the knight
now Fabia immediately takes this
opportunity to get his knife to this
excellent central outpost so 95 and
Bishop to e6 now developing and adding
another defender to the d5 pawn with f3
now keeping around efore in g4 but also
in the future we want to push efore so
that's basically preparing e4 Knight
back to d7 Hikaru
is very happy to trade down tray down as
many pieces as possible and of course
Fabi declines Knight to g4 we have
looked at I ate and now rook F to D 1 as
you are preparing to push f4 you want
the d4 point to be protected with bishop
characters and g4 biphobia H captures
and now Bishop to d6 just challenging
sorry by Hikaru just wanting to trade
more pieces and here a bunch of
characters on d6 with rook captures and
the Hikaru was able to trade off a lot
of pieces here but and now Fabi gets in
this very nice rook lift rook the b7 and
now it if possible he wants to push
efore which will of course put pressure
on c4 as well as just the center if you
get E 4 and E 5 in your position will be
very good
so Knight the f8 by Nakamura he wants to
shoot the night over to e 6 and now
Queen to f2 or when you push if or you
also want your d4 point to be to be
protected twice as the Queen and the
rook will be attacking it and now rook
the f6 now of course if if you push it
for this pawn captures and you cannot
recapture with the F pawn so Brooke did
the b1 Bobbie just doubles up on the B
file and now Queen to b6 and here he
curves as my position is is very nice
I've prevented you from pushing efore
and I I can just you know chill like
this for for as long as as I need to
and here the problem with something like
rook to b6 although it looks nice
Nakamura would very gladly just just
take it here and play 2 rooks against
the Queen and it
be very hard for Fabi to do anything
here if anything it's black was better
so if Abby finds g5 instead it says
where are you going with the rock my
bishop slices over here the pawn slices
here your own only square is e six so
this is what nakamura does and now e for
by Fabi
so is this breakthrough possible and
what what what's happening here
so he Carl doesn't like captures and
instead he goes for Quinta a theory but
it is it is quite a weird move to play
because Fabi just pushes e5 and we
already mentioned if white gets efore a5
in that his position will be good and
now the problem is when if I was played
you you can't even capture on a2 because
bunch of characters on h7 and you lose
the Queen here so a very very odd
decision by here by nakamura so instead
he just moves the rook rook H to e7 and
now wants the trade here and just look
the b5 by Fabi declining trade going
after the d5 pawn and now a second weird
decision bye-bye now
and now a second weird decision by
Nakamura now Queen to c3 and meadow
meadow was just frightened he probably
had a bit bad dream or something
so after rook 7 to b5 we have Queen to
c3 and now as it is a weird move just
rook captures on d5 just leaving that
point undefended and here it's unclear
what Quinta c3 does better than Queen to
c3 was just defending the pawn here but
Hikaru probably thinks he's gonna win
back the d4 pawn with the Knights the e6
so instead Luke captures on d5 and now
comes Knight the e6 challenging the d4
for now but it's already defended twice
here but maybe as the bishop is also
under attack you could maybe do some
tactics here however fob he finds the
very strong Bishop to a4 he goes for the
rook here and now rook to f8 getting the
rook out of harm's way and now f4 of
course you want to play f5 f6 and so on
now Fabi it really really does have the
initiative so g6 by Hikaru freeing up
the g7 square for his knight then you
can maybe go to f5 and well it's hard to
say as a
white always has this g4 move so rook to
d6 and now comes the Knight to g7 we
have Bishop back to C - of course f5
would be would be very nice for white
and now Knight the e8
we have rook the c6 and now are getting
the rock out of harm's way and now rook
the d7 so for the moment preventing f5
as now the d4 pawn is under attack we
have rook to d1 and now Knight the c7 so
what's what's happening here we have
Bishop the e4 now if Knight to d5 then
of course far we just racist and
continuous pushing and now rook F to d8
challenging the d4 form once again now
it's attacked three times and here Bobby
goes for Queen to f3 just a nice Queen
trade but f5 was actually incredibly
strong however both of them were very
low on time hikaru even more so and well
bobby was also in some you know to some
extent playing also on he calls time
so here it's very strong because you can
never trade here as your night will be
undefended here and if you play
something else and it's hard to find a
move let's say 95 now we just capture
here and you just capture everything
capture capture capture capture check
and doesn't matter where the King goes
can gauge seven Queen f6 and it's just
the game over so f5 would have been very
strong a mating attack if you will but
okay Fabiana went for Queen f3 as he
does have a very promising position
Nakamura captured here and now Knight
the e6 and now he's attacking both of
these pawns which means he's grabbing
back the pawn but a father found the d5
we have Knight captures on f4 and now d6
which really limits the mobility of the
black rooks and you will also be able to
undermine them later with Bishop to g4
so here at night the d3 closing of the D
file for fabi's rook but now a Bishop to
g4 forces the rook to move rook to e7
and now d7 and now we have a nicely
protected passport on d7 we have a king
to f8 and now rook captures on C for the
night now has to move with Knights to be
4 and here just a 6 Fabi doesn't give he
karo a moment's rest we have F captures
on e6 and now
characters on e6 now we look to a six by
hikaru going after the bishop but now
just rook the c8 saying okay you capture
here I'm gonna have her here with check
so King to e7 this is a must and Bishop
to g4 now so just defending the past
pawn and Hikaru is really running out of
options he played rook to e8 hoping of
course Fabia Fogg we will trade here but
Bobby does no such thing so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
winning move for Fabi while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
unsporting the best move in the position
and for those of you who just wanna
enjoy the show it's rook to e1 check now
you just push the pool to blacking away
it's it's all the same where the King
goes king of seven and now rook to e8
and it was in this position unmoved 50
that he caught Nakamura resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here if you don't do anything you're
just gonna lose the rook any captures
captures will work here and of course if
you capture then white just brings a
queen into the game and wins if you want
to be super precise than first you you
just get the King to a less less active
Square and then you capture you bring
the Queen captures captures and you are
up a whole rook of course completely
winning so after rook to e8 and Nakamura
resigned and Fabi prevails with the
white pieces in Armageddon which is very
strange and not that he won but I really
thought Nakamura would go for the white
pieces I don't know why here he was
black he he was confident that he will
hold the draw but in the end he just
wandered upon and Fabi was able to of
course to nurture that you know pawn up
situation to to a full point so here
Fabia begins to points and Nakamura
gains one as they both reached
Armageddon and before I forget here are
the standings after around 10 so let's
just check it out
sorry that's that's a bit a bit large
let me just make that smaller some
special effects here there we go yeah
these are the standings cross-table from
the chess 24 website as you can see top
for Bingley and he Cara Nakamura Magnus
Carlsen Fabiana Caruana
and
these are only the the preliminary round
so those four will go into the knockout
stages but we still have two more rounds
to go so anything that still happened
well not really anything future will not
be able to qualify as he has only three
points so even if he wins his next two
matches before reaching Armageddon
that's only nine points and Fabi already
has ten so he will not be joining the
top four but Maxime Yan and Anisha Gary
are still able to I think gear is also
able to qualify for the top four as if
he wins both of his matches he will have
the same as Fabi that's ten and since he
still has to play Fabi if he beats Fabi
he will have ten exactly the same as
Fabi and I think that's a very important
criteria for tie breakers that he may
qualify for further knockouts in instead
of Fabi but it's gonna be it's gonna be
very exciting so it's gonna be hard for
anyone who's not in the top four at the
moment to qualify but like I said two
more rounds anything can still happen so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it
the entire match I would like to thank
Terrence Nolan Jana rasca Steve Wacha
Thomas Connors and Roland molar for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video series
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Magnus Invitational until it finishes so
thank you all I will see soon and have
an excellent rest of your day